TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, y'all.
How are you doing?
God, I'll tell you, it's not
every day I get to deliver a
speech like this to
a packed house.
But everybody out there on the
internet, you're really
missing out.
This is "Get More From the
Google+ Platform." Hi, I'm
Timothy Jordan.
I will be your developer
advocate
for the next 60 minutes.
Let's just jump right in.
There are three things that
I want to talk about.
The first is implementation;
second, optimization; and
third is measurement.
And it's these three steps sort
of provide a foundation
for doing more with
most things.
But I'm going to go specifically
through how to
get more from the Google+
Platform.
And the idea is to get more
engagement from your users,
and to get more in value out of
that engagement at any one
of those steps.
Let's start with implement.
So I'm going to give you a
survey of some of the things
that you probably already
know about, and maybe
a couple new things.
First off, the easiest way to
implement the Google+ Platform
is to start with one
of our plugins.
We have a +1 button, which is
about letting visitors quickly
recommend your brand
and your content.
A Share button, which is an easy
way for people to share
content with their circles.
And it's particularly useful
when the +1 button doesn't
make sense.
For example, if you don't want
users to make a public action,
you want to give them
the option to just
make a private action.
Also sometimes, you
want that verb.
You want the verb "share"
within your UI.
And then, of course,
the badge there.
And the badge has a +1 button.
It also has a link to your
Google+ page and the ability
for users to add the page to
their circles right from your
site, without having to leave
and go to Google+.
And of course, the +1 and the
Share, whether they're on the
badge, or standalone,
all drive social
annotations in search.
And we just announced, a few
days ago, recommendations on
the +1 button.
How many of you all
have seen this?
Cool.
It's neat.
I mean, now you hover over
the button, and you get
recommendations for other
content on that same site.
It's giving the user
more value while
they're on your site.
And it's great for
interlinking.
We all know recommended content
is great for user
engagement and continued
capture.
So those are the plugins.
And remember, the plugins
are the place to start.
And the next step about
implementation I want to talk
about is putting the pieces
together, connecting the
things that you've already
implemented.
The table stakes here are
the identity on Google+.
That's your Google+ page,
and linking that
identity from your site.
That's something like the badge
or another link code
that's invisible on your page.
And then finally, making all of
that drive more clicks on
the ads that you're already
serving with AdWords.
And all of this centers around
your site and your brand.
And the goal is to make it a
single entity wherever Google
refers to it and uses it.
So starting with the
Google+ page.
The Google+ page is all about
just getting your identity on
Google and giving you the
ability to interact with your
audience in that personal,
Google+ way, with Circles,
with rich posts, with
conversations, with Hangouts.
Now on the page, you'll notice,
right there at the
bottom, is this little
website.
And this is great, because users
can go to your profile
and then click on that and
then go to your site.
But it's also a signal
to Google.
It's important to fill this out
because then Google knows
that the owner of this Plus page
has claimed that site as
the same entity.
That's step one.
And that's the website address
that, again, connects that
page to the site.
The next step is to claim the
Google+ page from your site.
And this creates a bidirectional
link.
So we have from the page to your
site, and then back from
your site to the page.
And then we can know, with
confidence, that both sides of
this equation agree, these
are the same entity.
Now, claiming that on your site
is as easy as adding the
Google+ badge.
And you get the benefits of that
+1, and the Follow button
right there on the page.
However, if you don't have room
for that on your home
page, or you want to link
it another way,
you can always add.
Right down the bottom
here, you'll
see a link rel publisher.
And that links to your
Google+ page as well.
All right, the last step here is
if you're using AdWords to
enable what we call
social extensions.
And what it does, is it makes
it so the +1's on your ads
share the same bucket of +1's
for that entity that I've been
talking about, which
is your brand.
And the cool thing about this,
it's really easy, too.
You'll notice the dialog
box there.
That's in your AdWords
management console.
You just go in there, add
in the Google+ page ID.
And now we know that that's
all the same entity.
And as I was going to say, the
cool plus about this, if you
have more +1's, that's more
opportunity for social
annotations.
Which means, I see on an ad that
my friend Will Norris has
+1'd this product, and I'm more
likely to click on it.
In fact, on average, you're 5%
to 10% more likely to click on
it, which as far as a CTR
lift, is pretty big.
All right, so we've
talked about
plugins, getting started.
And we've talked about
connections, making that all
have a little bit more value.
Let's go into some higher-order
features here,
starting with Hangouts.
Now, once we launched Google+,
and people started using
Hangouts out there in the world,
we knew something that
we thought was going to be
cool was really cool.
What people are starting
to do with
Hangouts is really amazing.
Here you see President Obama in
a Hangout, connecting with
American citizens.
Like that kind of discourse
is new, and absolutely
incredible.
But in addition to this sort
of front porch of the
internet, if you will, are the
ability to write your own
applications that users can play
with, can do work with,
with each other at
the same time.
Now,, there is a talk that
you should check out at
Google I/O this year.
It's "The Next Generation of
Social is in a Hangout."
Follow that link, you'll be
able to see the video and
check out the slides.
But some quick notes.
There's three main things.
One, it's easy integration
of video chat.
Once you make the app, video
chat just comes along for the
ride, it's baked in.
Simple APIs make your app real
time, so that people can
actually collaborate in this
application together, and the
ability to make it fun with
effects, face tracking and
video effects to make it more
of a joyful experience,
whether it's for work
or just for play.
And there's some examples on
this screen of really cool
Hangout apps.
And if you go to our demo
stations, you'll see some
really great Hangout apps
that people have built.
And there's a lot of
interactivity, and there's
some really fun nuance
in there.
But getting started is so
much easier than that.
You don't have to build
a full application.
All you have to do is put your
content in a Hangout.
And I want to show you
what this looks like.
OK, so I have an example site.
And you'll notice that it
is not the prettiest
thing in the world.
That was on purpose.
It's so that you can take
a look at the code.
And I'll give you
this URL later.
It's so that you can see these
things implemented in a
relatively clean environment.
I mean, I did add four shades
of gray, though.
So I hope it's a little
interesting.
I'm going to show you
this site, which is
Random World Photos.
And all it's doing is taking
some images from a Picasa
album on my account, and putting
them on the homepage.
And then when I click
into them, I see a
one-up of that image.
But I've also integrated the
Google+ platform throughout.
So you can see all the little
bits and pieces and how the
connections work together,
one of which is
this Hangout button.
And I wrote a Hangout app.
And it took me about
10 minutes.
All this Hangout app does is
start a Hangout with my
content in it.
And in this case, it's
just a simple image.
But you can imagine the content
on your site there.
It could be a simple image.
And that's interesting
and engaging.
Or it could be a video, or it
could be a live stream with
stats on the side.
So you see, here's this image.
And it was just on that
page of the site.
And now I'm in a Hangout,
spending time with my friends,
talking about this.
In this case, it's just a photo
I took out of a plane
while I was waiting
to take off.
But again, what if it
were your content?
What if it were breaking news?
And you just made this all
possible with, as you'll see
in just a moment, a
few lines of code.
So first off, here is the
link to the Hangout.
It's just an href that
includes a URL
with the data encoded.
You'll notice, right up here,
it says, gd equals.
And then I'm using some template
syntax to put in the
Hangout data.
In this case, I'm adding in
the URL to the image.
Now, you do want to be careful
of this data because it's
being sort of passed around
the internet.
And if somebody were to
intercept it and modify it,
then that could make it not the
Hangout experience that
you had intended.
So you just want to make sure
that when that data comes in,
that you verify it.
And there's a number of
different ways that
you could do that.
You could pull out the domain
and then insert your own
domain, just make sure it's
coming from the right place,
for example.
So this will grab the image from
our server, display that
button that when you click on
it, starts a Hangout, sending
in that data.
Now, the Hangout itself is first
defined by an XML file.
You'll notice in this XML
file a few things.
Right up at the top, we have
different features.
We have a title.
And then we're including the
Hangouts JavaScript.
Again, this is just really
a little bit of code.
And I copied and pasted this
from our documentation.
Now, this part here, this URL
application code, I added in a
couple things.
This is all you really
need to do.
I've got app data, where
I'm grabbing the app
data using the API.
And then I'm setting an image.
Now, down here below the script
tags, I would just put
in a tag for the image.
And that's just inserting
that.
So it's really three custom
lines of code to get my
content into a Hangout for a
full video chat experience
with people, my audience,
connecting over my content in
this new space.
Pretty cool, right?
But then where you
go from that--
that's where you start-- where
you go from that gets even
more exciting, adding in that
interactivity, using those
effects APIs, doing something
real time and collaborative is
where you get even more power
out of the Hangout.
Next thing is the Google+
History API.
Now, we just announced this this
week at Google I/O. And
it's an early developer
preview.
So it's not available
for users yet.
But it is available for
developers to start testing
and playing with and giving
us some feedback before we
release it to all users.
And this is the thing.
It's pretty much like
Instant Upload,
but for almost anything.
And who here is familiar
with Instant Upload?
Oh, there's still a few
people that aren't.
OK, this is how it works.
I have my phone.
I turn on Instant Upload.
Now every time I take a photo,
it gets uploaded in the
background to my Google+
account, to a private album.
So it's just for me.
I log in to Google+, and I see
all the photos I've taken that
day, that week, that
year, ever since I
turned on Instant Upload.
So it's cool.
Like, it's a safety thing
if I lose my phone.
But then it's also a
nostalgia thing.
I can go there, and just sort
of review all my photos,
whenever I want to.
And then finally, I can share
really easily, if I want.
I'm not going to share
all my photos.
But there's going to be a few
I want to share with my
friends circle, or
with public.
Google+ History is about making
that happen for a
user's activities online.
And the key thing here is for
that user to have the ability
to privately save their moments
into Google+ History,
and then optionally share
when they want.
Now, I'm giving a few talks
about this at Google I/O. If
it's of interest to you,
please check those out.
But let me give you a quick
overview of how it works.
First off, this is
the general path.
Get something, an activity that
the user performs online,
into Google+ History
as a moment.
And the user's history will be
filled with these moments.
And they're all just
for them, private.
And then when they want to, they
can share that activity
with their friends, their
family, their public,
however they want.
There's a few steps just
getting started.
First, you set up your
application.
Second, you authorize
the user.
And third, you write moments.
And these are using technologies
you're already
familiar with.
First off is the APIs Console.
Who's familiar with
the APIs Console?
Heard about it at Google I/O?
Oh.
For a few of you that aren't,
this is just a website at
developers.google.com/console,
where you define your
application, add the services,
like Google+ and Google+
History, that you want.
And then you can get something
like a client ID.
You then use that client ID to
start the OAuth process.
Your user will be presented
with a permission screen.
They add the permissions, get
directed back to your site,
and then you write moments.
And you use a RESTful
API to do that.
Essentially, you send a JSON
payload to this RESTful
endpoint that includes
a type--
the activity that was
performed, like a
comment or a listen--
and the target URL, which
is the activity that was
performed on like a blog
post, or the song.
And then finally, a result,
If there is a result.
So in the case of a comment, it
would be the comment that
you actually wrote.
Now, for writing moments,
again, just to take you
through that flow here we did
the write step, sending that
JSON payload.
But then there's this next
step of fetching.
Now, once Google gets the target
URL, it'll grab that
target URL and try
to determine what
that page is about.
Who here is familiar with
microdata markup?
Just a couple, OK.
This is really interesting and,
I think, increasingly
important for all publishers
to know about.
Microdata markup, it's in the
HTML5 spec, so it'll validate.
And then Schema.org uses
microdata markup with its own
types and item properties to
give your web page some
intelligence.
Without markup, a machine
reading your web page will
read a bunch of content.
But with the markup, you get
to tell that robot exactly
what your page is about, what
item it represents, of what
type, and what are the primary
properties it should use to
represent that item.
And in the case of Google+
History, we'll use those to
render a moment and, if the
user shares, a post that
include a rich image and the
title that you specify and a
link that you specify
back to the item.
And it turns out, Schema.org
markup is good for other
things as well.
In fact, it is the markup of
choice of all three major
search engines, both Yahoo
and Bing and Google.
So that's Google+ History.
It's all about giving your
users the ability to save
their moments privately, and
optionally share them with
whom they want.
Now, let's talk about mobile.
Now, we just had a mobile
session in here.
And if you want more information
about that, please
check out that session.
Francis and Julia go into a
lot of detail about what's
available for Google+.
I'll give you a quick
overview.
The Sign In button.
And this is something that's
also in developer preview,
that we released with the
Google+ History API, that
initiates the OAuth flow.
It's a button on your
page that we render.
You just set up some
attributes.
The user clicks on it, and
it starts that flow
automatically.
It makes it really easy to
get going with the API.
And it also does cool things
like login, and
cross platform identity.
And it's available
soon on mobile.
Widgets.
We've got the +1 and the
Share available.
And then, of course, the History
API is available, too,
so that users can save their
moments, not just from their
web activity, but also
from their mobile
app activity as well.
And again, that session,
"Integrating Google Into
Mobile Apps," with Julia and
Francis, is available online.
All right, let's look at a
couple more things on this
example site before
we move on.
I just wanted to point out some
of the things here that
I'm going to talk more about.
First off, we've got the badge
right up at the top.
And the badge comes in
two different sizes.
There's the bigger size that
includes a +1 button at the
bottom, or the one without.
I've chosen the one without.
You can make it dark.
You can make it light.
There's a little bit of
flexibility here for fitting
this into your page.
The +1 buttons, you'll
notice that I have
multiple ones on the page.
With the +1 button, you
can just sprinkle
these as you would.
It makes sense to have them on
leaf nodes, so they're the
representative of
a single item.
But you can also add them on
categories, to +1 that
category, or in a listing, so
that all those items, you can
+1 those before going into them,
if you just want to.
I can +1 these previews
of the image.
I don't have to go into
the image to +1 it.
I've also included on here
inline annotations.
So if people knew about this
website before today, they
would have +1'd here, and I
would see faces and names of
the photos that people like.
And when I click in, you'll see,
again, the +1 button and
the Hangout.
Now, if I were to +1 this,
which I'll do in another
example in a moment, you'll
notice it's highlighted here.
I go back to the home page,
highlighted there as well.
It's the same entity because
it's specified by the URL,
which is this.
This is the URL for this item.
We'll come back to this
in a few minutes.
So that's implementation.
It's a survey of a lot of our
platform elements and how they
work together, really
emphasizing the connections
between those things.
And a couple of the higher-order
stuff, like
Hangouts, and Google+ History,
and Mobile, which actually
have really accessible entry
points, but you can go pretty
far with them.
So for optimizing, there's
a few things I
want to talk about.
First off is that Schema.org
markup.
I talked about it
a little bit.
I want to give some
more detail.
And again, rendering the moment
or a post for Google+
History API is good.
But this Schema.org markup works
for everything that you
share on Google+.
So if a user grabs your URL and
pastes it in, we're going
to retrieve that page and look
for the same Schema.org markup
as if we do for History, or if
they share from the +1 button,
or when we're looking
to render rich
snippets on Google Search.
Now we'll look for other
markup styles as well.
Schema.org works the best
in this case, we think.
So we're going to look
for that first.
If we can't find it, we're then
going to look for Open
Graph markup.
If we can't find Open Graph
markup, we're going to look
for meta tags.
And if we can't find that, we'll
make our best guess.
Now, working up from the bottom,
our best guess, we're
pretty good guessers.
But given the choice, I would
imagine that you'd want to
specify how you look, rather
than have us guess.
Because for meta tags, you
can't do an image.
You can only do the title
and the description.
And they work pretty well, and
you can put them in the head.
But having that visual
component, we find, is really
powerful for having engaging
posts on Google+.
All right, so let's
look at what this
appears like in code.
Here is some Schema.org
markup.
Now, this is just a
body section with
not very much content.
I just want you to focus
on the markup here.
And it's these items.
So for those of you that
weren't familiar with
microdata markup, it's
essentially data that we put
inside the tag.
So there's these attributes,
item scope and item type.
You put that on the parent
tag to specify,
that's the whole item.
The item type's value is the
actual type from Schema.org
that you're specifying.
Now, there's some generic
types, and
some specific types.
You could make everything
a thing.
But then, the whole world knows
less about your site.
It can't put more intelligence
into it.
So by specifying, in this
case, a product, we get
additional attributes
that are very
product-specific that we can add.
Now, I've just included the
sort of generic attributes
that you'll always
want to include.
And those are name, image,
and description.
The name you'll see as the
title on that post.
The image is the thumbnail
that you'll see.
And the description is, of
course, that description below
both of those.
Now there's Open Graph.
And you'll see we have a
title, an image, and a
description.
And there's also the meta tag.
And you see the title
and the description.
Looking at this in a page, which
I think is always really
interesting, you'll see that
there's all sorts of content,
and then there's just these
highlights throughout that
represent the structured
markup.
Key takeaway here is
that first, the
user doesn't see it.
Whether you have the structured
markup or not, it
doesn't change the appearance
of your
web page in the browser.
Also, you don't have
to add any content.
Most likely, the content that
you would want to mark up is
already on your page.
You just have to indicate
what's already there.
And then finally, to reiterate,
adding the
structured markup to your
page makes it more
than just a web page.
It's adding this intelligence
that Google and other search
engines and Google+ can all
use to represent your page
with more clarity.
All right, so that's
structured markup.
Next up is speed.
I like that.
You want to see that again?
Really fast buttons.
[CHUCKLES]
So my friend John and Malte did
a session about this, "How
we Make JavaScript Widgets
Scream." And it's really
interesting, all the little
things they've done to make
these buttons appear as fast
as possible on the site.
And it's something that we're
always working on.
So in general, any
implementation you do should
have a fast button.
And it should get faster over
time, the better we get at it.
But if you want the specific,
fastest implementation, I
asked John, and he told
me this is it.
You'll notice a couple
quick things.
First off, we have the
script tag, right up
there at the top.
And it's including parsetags
explicit.
That means, this script is not
going to walk the DOM and look
for script tags.
It's going to wait until we
tell it exactly where to
render a button, which we do
right after the script tag.
Now, you would probably put
these at the bottom of your
body, but you could include them
right after the last tag
where you want to see
a button as well.
Now this gapi.plusone.render
method will allow you to
specify an ID.
That's the ID of the element
that you want to
replace with a button.
And then a JSON parameter bag.
And in this case, I'm
specifying an inline
annotation.
But any of the attributes on
the button you can include
here as parameters.
And then you'll see
these are the ID.
It just sort of links up with
that DIV tag at the top.
And of course, the annotation
is what gives
us this nice thing.
And let's just see that
in a template.
It looks a little
bit like this.
I'm showing a couple different
template examples.
And the idea is that with just
a couple changes, if you have
templating in place, you can
affect thousands of pages
across your site.
In this case, even if I have
tons of buttons on a page--
and this is simply the code for
the example site that I
showed you--
I can still specify each one
of those buttons with the
render function.
That's why they show up so
quickly on that site.
All right, so that's speed.
The next is user experience.
And there's just a couple
notes here.
I talk to publishers a lot.
And one of the questions I get
frequently is, how do I put
the buttons on my page so that
users will use them?
And I usually ask them, well,
it's like, I don't know.
You guys should experiment
with this.
But over time, we found that
there are at least two things
that are sort of obvious, but
let's just codify them, that
will get more clicks.
One of them is prominence.
If you hide the buttons away,
they're not going to get
clicked on as much.
It's sort of obvious.
But it's specific
to your site.
For some sites, it makes sense
to have it at the bottom
because everybody always reads
the whole article.
You have a really long bounce
time, which means people are
spending time on that page, and
they're scrolling down.
For other sites, a lot of users
might just be reading
the title or the paragraph, or
whatever the user behavior is.
Maybe they're more likely
to click at the
top or at the bottom.
But having that correct
prominence for your site is
what's essential.
The next thing is grouping.
This is sort of obvious.
It's that social actions are
very familiar with each other.
You put them together so users
know where to go to click.
And here's an example on the
New York Times website.
And you'll see, right up at the
top of the article there,
we have those social actions so
that users on the Times can
share this right away.
I also wanted to show an
example from Time.
Again, this is right
below the headline
and before the article.
And what you'll notice that
these two sites is you go to
article to article to article,
and it's very predictable
where those buttons are.
And they're always
easy to find.
They're always near
each other.
So I would switch back to the
site, but we already saw this.
Remember, the +1 button is
next to each image, very
predictable where that is.
And when you go to the actual
image page, the +1 button and
the Hangout are right
there together, the
same on all the pages.
Oh, you know what?
There's one more other thing
I'd like to show you too,
before we move on.
So I told you I was going to
+1 something in a moment.
Let's do that right now.
And you'll notice, a couple
things happen.
On this site, something happens
that happens on every
other site.
The Share box comes up.
You +1 something, you
get a Share box.
Another thing happened, which
is, I think, pretty obvious,
is that we got a big red border
around the image.
Sort of a silly thing to do.
But I'm demonstrating
a signal here.
And that signal is, when
the user clicks on
it, something happens.
And something happens on your
site, not just on Google.
These social annotations are
important, because when I +1
something, Will may see that
later and be like, oh,
Timothy +1'd that.
That's important.
But making them important
on your site,
too, is really helpful.
In this case, on this particular
site, you'll see
that red border around the
image on the image page.
And now, when I go back to the
landing page, all the images
I've +1'd have this
red border.
So this signal has indicated
to me my favorite
images on this site.
And what else could
you do with this?
Aside from just indicating to
the user or thanking them, you
could keep track of what
they're +1ing.
And you could recommend, at
the moment of the click,
alternate content.
Hey, you +1'd this hat.
Here are three other hat
similar that you might
want to check out.
You can do that based on that
action with just, again, a few
lines of code.
And it looks like this.
I put this code together, again,
in the render function
so you could see the callback
in context of, again, using
that render function to
get them to render
really, really fast.
And it's just this
item right here.
I'm specifying the +1 callback
identifier as a function in
the global JavaScript namespace
that should be
called when the user clicks
the +1 button.
I just threw it in the
parameter bag.
Remember where I specified
inline annotations earlier?
Same thing.
And I need to make sure to
define that function, again,
in the global JavaScript
namespace of the page.
Here it is, +1 callback.
And it receives a parameter
that I'm calling data.
And the first thing I do on this
particular site is I get
the ID of the photo, which
I'm actually just
pulling from the URL.
I then set a cookie.
And then finally, if
the state is on--
oh, it's yellow here, I
changed it to red--
but either way, I'm setting
a border on the image.
And if it's off, I'm removing
that border.
And then finally, when I
render these buttons--
just coming back to the code
you saw a few frames ago,
you'll notice this code
down here as well--
is if the cookie was
set to on, I
render that border again.
Now, the border is,
again, just sort
of an example signal.
So you can see the functionality
of this, and so
it can get your ideas flowing.
But also, so it makes it
easy to implement.
But what else could you do on
your particular site that
makes it really valuable for
the user on your site that
they +1 something?
OK.
So we've done implement.
We've done optimize.
Let's now talk about
measurement.
So you can measure the value
of the +1 button and how
people are using it using
Google Analytics.
And you can also do it using
Webmaster Tools.
Now, Google Analytics will show
you engagement on these
buttons and who's
clicking what.
And Webmaster Tools will give
you some really cool things,
like the +1's on your site,
understanding them a bit more,
and the CTR uplift.
But of course, this is
a developer talk.
So I want to talk a little bit
about our own code, and to
mention that you can write
custom analytics.
In this particular case, I'm
using the +1 button.
Now remember, the +1 button has
a callback, which I can
use to drive my own analytics
on my own site.
And that's what this
is right here.
This +1'd function is getting
called when the user clicks on
the +1 button.
And then, if it's on, I'm
sending a signal to my custom
analytics that it was a +1.
And if it's off, I'm sending a
signal to my analytics that it
was un+1'd, if you will.
It's pretty neat, right?
All right, so when I was putting
this together, I
thought, well, what else could I
do that was kind of fun that
used the API?
Now this is not a robust
analytics solution.
I wouldn't say, deploy this
at your organization.
But it does demonstrate how easy
it is to use the API to
get a little bit of data out of
Google so that you can make
the experience better on
your Google+ page.
You'll notice, on every
post that you make,
there's these numbers.
There's the +1's, there's
the reshares.
There's also the number
of comments, if
you count them up.
And that gives you an idea of
how users are engaging with
the content that you publish
from that Google+ page.
+1's are that me too action.
It's very easy for users to add
that when they feel some
sort of affinity.
Reshares are that viral reach.
The more of those you have, the
more places your content
is getting, the more groups
are seeing it.
And then comments, those are
your direct interaction with
your content.
And all of this is available
in the API.
So if what you wanted to do
was sort of improve your
posting over time, you
could just pay
attention to these numbers.
And for fun, I threw it
into an app script.
So it looks like this.
There's a spreadsheet that pulls
the API and fills out a
bunch of information based
on the posts I've made.
And it gives me some graphs.
And it looks like this.
Here's the app script itself.
And this is all sort of
spreadsheet information,
except for this one thing.
We get the feed of
all of my posts
using this fetch request.
And then the rest is really
just parsing.
I'm going to show you what
that looks like for fun.
All right, so this is
the spreadsheet.
And you'll see that it has a
URL to all of my things.
And I've gone here, and
I've categorized them.
And then it sets automatically
the +1's,
comments, and reshares.
And you can see, I can get a
summary of all that data.
And I make my own graphs.
And this is all because of
some simple app script.
Now again, this is
not a robust or
dependable analytic system.
You wouldn't want to build
a business on this.
But it's really a great
place to start.
If you're already doing things
with the Google+ API, if
you're already working with this
stuff, you could use this
data in that product.
But the spreadsheet was fun.
And I'll give you that code as
well if you ask me on Google+.
So just to recap.
There are these three
big things.
This is implementation,
adding items your page
and connecting them.
There's this optimization,
getting them to be faster,
putting things in
the right place.
There's this measurement,
knowing what is working and
what's not.
If you put the button
at the top, are you
getting more +1's?
Or if you put it at the
bottom, are you
getting more +1's?
And then, of course, there's
always this last
step, which is repeat.
We're always adding
functionality that you can
insert on an implement phase and
using your measurement to
really hit that optimization
phase again and again, until
you're getting the most value
out of each of these
components.
And that's it.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do we
have any questions?
Oh, and I should mention
this as well.
I always forget to.
If you liked this talk, please
put one of these in those
boxes back there, +1's.
It's like a real life +1.
Isn't that neat?
So please, questions.
AUDIENCE: You showed putting the
border around images when
someone +1's on that device.
Is there a way to keep that
border when they visit your
site on another device,
where just a
cookie wouldn't do that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So that's
a great question.
In this case, I've implemented
that persistent
data using a cookie.
So the user has to be on the
same browser, has to be the
same user, can only get
it from that domain.
But obviously, if I was going
to persist this data over a
long time, I'd want something
more robust in my own database
that I'm submitting that to.
And of course, you could use
that on multiple devices.
And to take that one step
further, if you're using the
Sign In button, you've got the
user's identity from Google+,
and you can use that correlate
that across multiple devices,
because that's available
soon on Mobile as well.
AUDIENCE: So once the user is
authorized, then the data will
include the user identity
as well?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So the
authorization process, once
the user grants access, and you
get that callback, you get
their Google+ ID.
Then it's up to you to
store that data.
AUDIENCE: You store
it to the session.
OK, got it.
Yeah.
Question I have, the Open Graph
tags or microtagging,
how often is it updated?
Let's say I +1 the URL,
and one week later,
I change the title.
What will be the
effect of that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So that's
a great question.
When we fetch that page, we
respect the cache headers that
you're setting.
So as soon as that cache
expires, if a user creates a
new post, we will
refetch that.
AUDIENCE: And essentially, the
user post will change?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So if a user's
already made a post, that post
does not change, but
new posts do.
All right, because you wouldn't
want to pull the rug
under the user
AUDIENCE: Why not?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Or change
the content.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, the reason
is because, and we
believe really strongly in this
at Google, is you don't
want to surprise the user.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, you know.
OK.
Any other questions?
Well, OK.
Thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]